this video is sponsored by blue apron
hey wisecrack Jerrod again pour yourself
a cold glass of milk cuz today we're
talking about Jordan peels social
thriller get out while many films
explore race in America
what makes get out so unique is that it
doesn't go after the usual targets but
instead takes aim at an unlikely mark
white liberals welcome to this wisecrack
edition on get out and of course
spoilers ahead but first a quick recap
get out follows Chris Washington as he
meets his white girlfriend's parents for
the first time while the first half of
the film explores white liberals
awkwardly attempting social interaction
with a black man the second half of the
film takes a pretty horrific turn after
we find out that the party hosted by
roses parents is in fact a slave auction
of sorts we learn an even more
terrifying truth an old white man wants
his brain implanted inside of Chris's
body you have been chosen because of the
physical advantages you enjoyed your
entire lifetime with your natural gifts
and our determination we could both be
part of something greater something
writer-director Jordan Peele said that
the story came to him after reflecting
on how many Americans thought the Obama
presidency signified a post-racial era
the film argues that so-called
post-racial liberalism is something more
terrifying than most would imagine
throughout the film Chris is confronted
with quote totally not racist white
people who have moved beyond racism it
explores how this disavowal seems to
reinforce the relationship with black
people that is at its best suspicious
and at its worst well we'll get there
but the first act shows how the attempts
of people to show Chris how not racist
they are only serves to further alienate
him so how long is this been going on
this thing the Armitage family seems
unnaturally eager to bring up black
people's stuff around Chris as if this
proves that they're not racist
by the way I I wouldn't
for Obama for a third term if I could
best president my life to have hands
down this tendency to over perform the
acceptance of all things black only
further cements the difference between
them and makes Chris extremely
uncomfortable Chris just wants to get
through the weekend and take some
pictures but everyone around him can't
help reminding him that he's black thus
only making him feel more different
Gordon was a professional golfer four
years
Kida well I can't quite the swing the
hips like I used to though but uh I
dunno tiger this also leads to a
situation where any actual racism can be
excused as long as they can show how
down they are with black culture and
anti-racist ideas come on I get it white
family black servants total cliche I
wasn't gonna take you there
well you didn't have to believe me the
second act exposes Chris to a bunch of
white people all fascinated with Chris's
blackness party guests want to know what
it's like to be black in America and
even feel compelled to tell him that
black is in fashion there's a term for
white fascination with black culture
that can help us better understand get
out negro philia the term emerged in
1920s Paris to describe the craze for
black culture amongst the hipsters of
the day writer Petrine Archer straw
writes that for these young Parisians
blackness was a sign of modernity such a
privilege to be able to experience
another person's culture but this had a
problematic flip side black
personalities were either lionized or
demonized in a matter that denied
normality in other words they could
never be you know actual people and
instead existed as one of two
stereotypes brilliant artists or
uncultured animals throughout the film
we see both sides of this chris is
celebrated for his cultural background
yet as the creepy brother reminds us if
you really push to body beast
to paraphrase Archer straw in both cases
it's the white perspective that decides
how black people are defined and this
Negro philia isn't just confined to the
desire for black culture it can be the
desire for the black body itself both
sexually
is it true is it better and athletically
so Chris what's your support and while
you might be tempted to think is it so
bad to be desired because you're sexy
and strong well the answer is yeah
necrophilia isn't about truly
understanding black people and their
culture it's about using them to satisfy
your own desires this is not
understanding humans it's collecting
them and while get-out exemplifies
classic negro philia we see it take a
leap forward to the literal colonization
of the black body in the third act early
in the film we learned about grandpa
Armitage his experience of being bested
by a black athlete my dad's claim to
fame was B by Jesse Owens in the
qualifying round for the Berlin Olympics
in 1936 those are the ones were always
won in front of him yeah what a moment
what a moment
I mean Hitler's up there with all his
perfect Aryan race [ __ ] this black
dude comes along proves him wrong in
front of the entire world
amazing tough break for you dad no yeah
I almost got over well it turns out that
his inability to get over it led him to
have his brain implanted into an
athletic black body and Grandma Armitage
well turns out her brain was placed in
georgina so she could spend her golden
years playing dress up as a beautiful
black woman and of course Chris has said
on a track for a similar fate when he's
auctioned off to a blind man who wants
his award-winning photographer eyes and
in an extreme version of liberal racism
Chris's new owner refuses to attribute
his purchase to racism
please don't love me into that you know
I could give a [ __ ] what color you are
know what I want
is deeper I want those things you see
through while a white person wanting to
literally transform into a black person
might sound preposterous there's at
least one American who wishes this was a
reality well I don't identify as
african-american identify as black so I
am part of the pan African Diaspora the
film also offers insight into the
psychological experience of black
Americans navigating white America
before the title screen we see a black
guy lost in the white suburbs a metaphor
for what's to come
creepy confusing as supper over the
physical maze of white suburbia sets a
clear parallel for the emotional maze
that Chris will have to navigate many of
Chris's interactions seem modulated
specifically for his white audience like
during interactions with the police Rose
seems content to make a scene while the
only thing Chris wants to do is not piss
off a cop no no [ __ ] that you don't have
to give him your idea cuz you haven't
done anything wrong maybe be nice okay
cool or when he suspects someone's been
tampering with his phone he quickly
drops the issue to not make a scene with
roses family forget it man no no no stop
don't don't do that don't okay I'm sorry
it's all good right even something as
simple as meeting his girlfriend's
parents leads Chris to worry they know
him do they know him black and being one
of the only people of color at the party
leaves Chris anxiously trying to
navigate this overwhelmingly white space
Illinois sometimes there's too many
white people are getting nervous you
know philosopher Frantz Fanon described
his own similar experience as a black
man living in 20th century france phenom
described meeting the white man's eyes
as placing a burden some weight upon him
one that left him feeling uncomfortable
in his own body and out of place in a
world dominated by whiteness like phenom
chris is burdened by the weight of
trying to fit in a world from which he's
fundamentally excluded good is he
brother round here
he's caught trying to integrate into
Rosa's world while at the same time
trying to retain his identity is that
they haven't met a black person it
doesn't work for this force is Chris to
be two people at the same time a black
man with his own identity and Rosa's
black boyfriend who's nice to everyone
do you find the vid African Omega as
more advantage no matter how absurd
their questions to navigate this chris
has to silence his own identity they
processed me literal during a late-night
chat with roses mother eventually
viewing his own reality through a screen
know you're in the second place this is
the name for a hypnotic state in which
one's mind is separated from their body
and they're left to passively view their
own experiences through a screen when
asked about the meaning of the sunken
place Jordan Peele tweeted that the
sunken place means were marginalized no
matter how hard we scream the system
silences us according to this logic any
society built upon inequality will
inevitably leave those on the outside
without a voice or at best with a
tempered version of their horse ones
true identity has to remain in the
background for the sake of going with
the flow we can understand the sunken
place better with some help from
sociologist w eb des bois who coined the
term double consciousness according to
the boys double consciousness is the
internal conflict experienced by
african-americans living in a
structurally racist society these
societal conditions lead black people to
see themselves through the perspective
of the dominant societal force in this
case white people chris is repeatedly
evaluated by the measuring tape of white
society and in particular certain forms
of white desire the experience of being
constantly examined leads to what Dubois
calls a Tunis of the black soul one
feels his Tunis and American a negro two
souls two thoughts two unreconciled
strivings two warring ideals in one dark
body whose dogged strength alone keeps
it from being torn asunder this
imposition leads to confusion about the
authenticity of one's experiences she
died in my head and how think I was
[ __ ] up
I don't want to think about and for
Chris this double-consciousness has left
him feeling like a helpless spectator if
you were wondering why Chris seems to be
haunted by the deer he and Rose killed
it may not be because he's some kind of
PETA activist but because watching
helplessly as a living thing died
probably reminded him of his mother's
death I told you about that night my mom
died I did call my old one to go out
looking for her when I would buy into in
other words the sunken place seems not
only to be a hypnosis technique but a
metaphor for his own life as a helpless
spectator this fear of losing oneself is
made literal in the coagula procedure in
which black consciousness is literally
pushed to the background to make room
for the white mind thus he risks being
permanently cast into the sunken place
Chris is able to avoid this fate by
plugging his ears with cotton picked
from his chair which brings to mind poet
audre Lorde's famous insistence that the
Masters tools will never dismantle the
Masters house for Lord this meant that
it was futile for the oppressed to use
the logic of the oppressor in their
attempts at resistance instead get out
suggest the opposite Chris uses a type
of labour associated with slavery
picking cotton to assert his own
identity and avoid a type of slavery
Chris not only uses cotton to avoid
bodily colonization he repurposes a
bocce ball arguably a symbol of the
white elite to take out Jeremy not to
say that bocce balls are blatantly white
objects but the only thing whiter would
be playing hacky sack at a Phish concert
and hauling back to the symbol of
Chris's spectatorship Chris takes a
mounted deer and go straight for Dean's
jugular with it a sign he's overcome the
powerlessness he once feared Chris's
emancipation from this near enslavement
can be seen as a radical assertion of
his black identity while chris is able
to escape the Armitage plantation of
horrors the real hero of get out and the
film's comic relief is his best friend
rod throughout the film rod serves as
the voice of reason why people love
making people sex slaves of [ __ ] and
eventually goes to the police once he's
put together a theory for why chris has
gone
missing after a revealing conversation
with Rose I know you think about [ __ ]
me rod he decides it's time to come to
Chris's rescue one [ __ ] she is like a
mother I know that but before rod saves
the day the film's most terrifying scene
comes from an unexpected source we all
know what's likely to happen if the
police show up and see a black man
kneeling over the bleeding body of a
white woman while the film's intended
ending was this devastating worst-case
scenario peel opted for a more
triumphant conclusion in the final cut
but the moment between the police sirens
and Rod getting out of the car is a
stark reminder that the real monster of
get out isn't a fictional boogeyman but
rather the horrors of the system itself
something that cannot be heroically
defeated at the conclusion of a film and
the other lesson of get out well that
one is more obvious I'm TS [ __ ]
a we handle [ __ ] that's what we do
consider this situation [ __ ] a handle
thanks for watching guys peace you know
what else you can consider handled your
meal situation and there's one thing I
love to pair with a good movie it's
delicious free food and blue apron has
got me covered if you're one of the
first hundred wisecrack fans to sign up
at the link in the description below it
can be your next favorite thing too for
real blue apron is offering three free
meals to the first hundred wisecrack
fans who sign up from this video that's
free food guys I mean it doesn't get any
better than that just make sure you do
it at the link in the description below
blue apron delivers farm-fresh
ingredients that look and taste amazing
and while I still only have the cooking
skills of a college freshman we had no
problem following the super-easy
directions with all the pre measured
ingredients and we cooked a crazy good
meal also Ryan had a lot of fun smelling
it all and this month blue apron has
more delicious meals on tab including
mozzarella and arugula paninis chicken
and sweet pepper tostadas roasted onion
miso ramen and more if you love food and
want an easy way to cook great meals at
home check out blue apron they deliver
fresh ingredients with delicious recipes
and it all comes in a refrigerated box
so ingredients stay fresh even if you're
not home when it arrives shipping is
always free good you can skip or cancel
service at any time so if you're looking
to expand
you're cooking repertoire and hate
grocery shopping as much as I do or just
love the idea of fresh ingredients
delivered to your door
check out blue apron at the link in the
description below and remember get your
free food now the first hundred
wisecrack fans to sign up with that link
get three free meals
thanks to blue apron for sponsoring this
video that's all for now guys all this
talking is making me pretty hungry
so don't forget to subscribe and ring
that Bell peace guys